رئيس الاوكرانيه
لم يسمها بالمساهمه في صناعه الصواريخ
الروسيه وقال انها تشكل انتهاكا للعقوبات
المفروضه على موسكو كما اشار زيلينسكي الى
ان محطه مهدده بمخاطر الجنه
مبينا ان معلومات استخباراتيه تفيد بوجود
نيه لدى روسيا لتفخيخها حسب قولها
صواريخ عده يستخدمها الارهابيون الروس ضد
اوكرانيا تحتوي على مواد تصنعها شركات في
العالم الحر لا يمكن التسامح مع هذا الامر
يجب علينا العمل معا للحد من استخدام
روسيا تقنيات العالم الحر فيها هجماتها
على اوكرانيا اما بالنسبه لمحطه زبروج
النوويه فلا يمكن التسامح مع ما تفعله
روسيا هناك اسمحوا لي ان اذكركم بان هذه
اكبر محطه للطاقه النوويه في اوروبا لدينا
معلومات استخباريه تؤكد وجود نيه لدى
روسيا لتفخيخها عرضنا هذه المعلومات على
دبلوماسيين اوروبيين